okay so i you can do this
externally so you're going to start a
tilting his body
and you take his balance uh by
using the young hand and moving his
line of gravity outside these faces
before
you're doing that i can do a projection
style
and do the same thing okay so i what i'm
going to do
here is externally yield so his momentum
comes
pop onto the other hand and do a
projection cooking projection
so you can do that i would say that's a
little more advanced than
uh you know just working on a line of
gravity and basic support
all right uh then uh you can
um more have him so on on this one
there's more of a
of an adhesion so open open your grip so
as i do my grip i'm
having adhesion there as opposed to a
get out of his way and let him
fall into it okay so i use the adhesion
with the pokey projection so i can tease
that might be a little higher uh and
then with all those all of these skills
i could start i could start relaxing
relaxing uh and then what you can do is
you can get you don't need the geometry
you you already have um his center
all right just relax
so if and then once you can do that you
can go back to
the um the disequilibrium geometry but
it's done by the same
it's done by the same mechanism
[Music]
so as you're working focus you're trying
to get
better at your art not just
trying to do coq okay
so at the lower levels you're using this
kind of
uh you know disequilibrium engine
but at the midpoint you
you'll have like you see at the moment
of contact
i already have the center at the lower
levels
you don't have a center now you're doing
this kind of you know
topsy-turvy and then you catch the
center at the end
but at the beginning levels you already
have the center which is
why you don't need those uh this this
balance breaking thing
so right when it grabs you already have
the center you can do
you get it you can do it so here i don't
have a center
and then now i have but here i don't
have the center
and now but on the other one you already
have this thing
that's why you don't need those you
don't need those okay
but does that mean i can't do the other
one
and still have a set i can't do i can do
this yield
and this projection but have this center
from the beginning
do you see so but i can't
get to that level if all i'm doing is
this external stop
where you're just using joint
manipulation you don't have this center
yet so already you'll have the center
and the way you can show that you have
this sensor is you don't need to
even use the external disequilibrium
models
okay